Guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Ekrem Özfali.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Astonarzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne heute mit Ihnen ein Aufnahmegespiel durchführen.
Alles in Ordnung?
Ja Herr Doktor, bitte.
Am Anfang benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten.
Dann können wir weiterführen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Maria Stetner.
Maria Stetner.
Können Sie bitte den Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, das buchstabiert sich M wie Martha, A wie Anton, R wie Richard, I wie Ida, A wie Anton.
Maria und Stetner buchstabiert sich S wie Samuel, T wie Theodo, E wie Emil, Doppel T wie Theodo, N wie Nordpol, E wie Emil, R wie Richard.
Vielen Dank, vielen Dank Frau Stetner.
Frau Stetner, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt Herr Doktor.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin 1 Meter 67 groß.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 69,5 Kilo.
Frau Stetner, was für eine Saison ist das? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe seit gestern Abend starke Bauchschmerzen.
Ich möchte ehrlich gesagt einfach nur Hilfe gegen die Schmerzen.
Seit gestern, das müssen wir wollen.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Hier oben im Oberbauch.
Meistens fühle ich den ganzen Bauch.
Manchmal fühle ich den ganzen Bauch, aber meistens im Oberbauch.
Meistens im Oberbauch.
Sind die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich langsam aufgetreten?
Ja, langsam abgetreten.
Langsam, langsam.
Alles gut.
Jetzt, die Schmerzen sind dauerhaft oder phasenweise?
Herr Doktor, wie gesagt, es hat langsam angefangen und ist dann schlimmer geworden.
Sie sind immer dauerhaft.
Aber nicht in gleicher Stärke.
Ich verstehe.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo aus?
Nein Herr Doktor, das habe ich nicht.
Gibt es einen Auflöser für die Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe mit Brötchen und Tiramisu gegessen.
Könnten die Schmerzen davonkommen?
Ja, es kann astrolitisch sein.
Gestern Abend haben Sie gegessen oder?
Nein, gestern Abend.
Mit Brötchen und?
Ja, frühabend habe ich mit Brötchen und Tiramisu gegessen.
Dann hatte ich ein paar Stunden diese Schmerzen.
Mit Brötchen und Tiramisu.
Gibt es jemanden, der mit Ihnen gegessen hat?
Nein, ich war allein.
Ich habe aus dem Supermarkt gekauft Tiramisu und mit Brötchen habe ich zu Hause vorbereitet.
Wissen Sie schon, war das Essen noch frisch?
Wie gesagt, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Haben Sie etwas komisch aufgefallen oder?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ja, dumpf Herr Doktor und krampfartig.
So Wellenförmig, wissen Sie?
Ja, Wellenförmig, dumpf, krampfartig.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen? Wie beschreiben Sie auf einer Schmerzkala?
0 ist keine Schmerzen, 10 ist sehr stark. Wie würden Sie beschreiben?
Ich würde sagen 6 Herr Doktor oder 7.
6 oder 7.
Frau Stettner, gibt es noch anderes?
Vielleicht noch Übelkeit, Erbrechen?
Ja, schon seit gestern habe ich Übelkeit.
Und ich musste dreimal erbrechen Herr Doktor.
Ja, wie gesagt, das erbrichten aus.
Drinnen gab es verdauertes Essen und es war gelblich und schleimig.
So dreisch Herr Doktor.
Auch Esseneste oder?
Ja.
Haben Sie noch Durchfall?
Ja Herr Doktor, seit heute Morgen.
Seit heute Morgen?
Ja.
Wie sieht das Stuhl aus?
Ja, es sieht wässrig und schaumig aus.
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Aus, als war er hellrot, jetzt ist er dunkelrot.
Meinen Sie am Anfang, das war hellrot?
Ja.
Aber jetzt ist er dunkelrot.
Er ist dunkelrot.
Alles gut.
Gibt es noch andere Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel Herzrasen, Schwitzen?
Ja, Herzrasen habe ich, ich denke Herr Doktor.
Mein Herz klopft irgendwie schneller.
Irgendwie schneller, ja.
Woraus kommt Herzrasen?
Sie haben aktuell Übelkeit, Erbrüche und Durchfall.
Vielleicht haben Sie schon viel Fristigkeit verloren.
Deswegen es kam.
Frau Stetner, haben Sie Fieber?
Wie fühlen Sie sich?
Ja, ich fühle mich auch Fieber, Herr Doktor.
Gestern hatte ich 39 Grad, heute 38,3.
Gestern 39 Grad, heute 38,3.
Wann haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Gestern?
Gestern.
Heute habe ich das zwei Mal gemessen.
Wo haben Sie das gemessen? Achille oder Mund?
Ich weiß nicht, was Achille ist, aber ich habe unter Arm gemessen.
Unterarm? Entschuldigung.
Haben Sie noch Müdigkeit?
Ja, ich fühle mich auch müde, Herr Doktor.
Müdigkeit. Und schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, ich schlafe schlecht. Ich habe viel Stress, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe im Moment viel Stress bei der Arbeit, wegen der Konkurrenz.
Meine Tochter hat ein Drogenproblem.
Auf diesen Gründen kann ich nicht gut schlafen, Herr Doktor.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie. Ich verstehe, dass Sie Angst haben. Es tut mir leid.
Frau Stettner, haben Sie seit gestern Durchfall und Erbrüche?
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie noch andere Probleme beim Wasserlassen haben?
Mit Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme, Herr Doktor.
Kein Problem beim Wasserlassen. Alles gut.
Frau Stettner?
Es ist auch ein bisschen dunkel, weil ich viele Flüssigkeiten verloren habe.
Ja, natürlich.
Je nach Ihrer Erklärung habe ich es so verstanden.
Wie viel dunkel? Zum Beispiel ein Tee oder Altbeer?
Nicht so stark, aber ein bisschen dunkler als vorher.
Ja, ein bisschen dunkler als vorher.
Ich verstehe.
Frau Stettner, leiden Sie an anderen chronischen Erkrankungen?
Was meinen Sie mit chronischen?
Ich habe es nicht. Zum Beispiel Bronchitis, Zuckerkrankung oder Bluthochdruck.
Ich habe keine Zuckerkrankung oder Bluthochdruck.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es chronisch ist, aber ich habe oft Kopfschmerzen.
Kopfschmerzen?
Ich habe einen Reizmagen.
Reizmagen?
Ja, früher, vor ein paar Jahren, hat mein Hausarzt gesagt.
Reizmagen.
Reizmagen. Seit wann haben Sie Reizmagen?
Vielleicht vor etwa neun Jahren.
Neun Jahre.
Ich habe manchmal Sodberinnen, ungefähr einmal im Monat.
Einmal im Monat.
Nehmen Sie Degit mit Clementine oder?
Seit etwa zehn Jahren habe ich jeden Tag Hüsten.
Jeden Tag Hüsten. Rauchen Sie, Frau Stettner?
Ja, ich rauche leider.
Rauch Hüsten. Frau Stettner?
Nein.
Besuchen Sie Ihren Hausarzt regelmäßig oder?
Nein, ehrlich gesagt schon lange nicht mehr.
Frau Stettner, würden Sie schon mal operieren?
Muss ich meinen Hausarzt viel besuchen?
Ja, nicht so viel, aber ...
Warum haben Sie danach gefragt? Ich frage mich deswegen.
Man sollte immer regelmäßig Ihren Mars besuchen.
Für alle, für Ihre Gesundheit.
Nicht nur diese Probleme, sondern auch andere Probleme.
Wie oft soll ich besuchen?
Ca. drei oder sechs Monate.
Dann können Sie mit Ihrem Hausarzt besprechen.
Wie oft besuchen Sie?
Das ist zu häufig.
Ja, nein, nicht drei oder sechs Monate.
Nein, nicht zu häufig.
Würden Sie schon mal operieren, Frau Stettner?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es eine Operation ist.
Aber ich habe mit Saatglocken geboten.
Ist das eine Operation?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Aber das ist eine invasive Methode.
Aber keine Operation.
Was ist eine invasive Methode?
Das klingt ein bisschen ertönt.
Sie haben es richtig.
Eine intensive Geburtmethode.
Aber nicht nur ...
Ich kann nicht richtig verstehen.
Die erste Sprechwache, Herr Doktor.
Invasive, intensive kann ich nicht gut verstehen.
Ich bin einfach ein Taxifahrer.
Ich bin nicht ein ausgebildeter Mensch.
Sie haben es richtig.
Eine Geburtmethode.
Wie soll ich sagen?
Okay, danke.
Nehmen Sie mit KMN regelmäßig ein.
Wegen dieser Schlafstörung nehme ich Baldrian.
Herr Doktor, bei Bedarf.
Und gegen Kopfschmerzen nehme ich Aspirin.
Aspirin?
Ja.
Wie viel?
Halbe Gramm.
Was kommt?
Und gegen Bauchschmerzen nehme ich Maloxan.
Gegen Bauchschmerzen?
Ja.
Seit wann?
Seitdem bei mir eine Diagnose festgestellt wurde.
Vielleicht seit neun Jahren.
Neun Jahre.
Maloxan.
Hat er es verabschieden?
Hat er verabschieden.
Ja.
Frau Schett, haben Sie Allergie gegen etwas?
Herr Doktor, ja.
Ich habe Allergie gegen Amoxicillin.
Eine Antibiotika.
Eine Antibiotikum.
Ja.
Ich bekam Atemnot und musste ins Krankenhaus.
Da habe ich Adrenalin bekommen.
Ja, mit Atemnot.
Ach so.
Ich habe das notiert.
Amoxicillin.
Reagieren Sie mit Maloxidant.
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Wie gesagt, rauche ich etwa zehn Zigaretten täglich.
Seit wann?
Seit meinem sechzehnten Lebensjahr.
Sechzehnten Lebensjahr.
Sechzehnten.
Herr Doktor, Sie stellen viele Fragen.
Ich möchte nur Hilfe für meine Schmerzen.
Ja, aber ich muss alle Fragen, alle Untersuchungen durchführen.
Nach dem Aufnahmegespräch, wir können weiterführen.
Aber ich habe noch ein paar kurze Fragen.
Okay, Herr Doktor.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke zwei Gläser Wein pro Woche.
Ein paar pro Woche.
Und geräglich Bier.
Pro Woche.
Alles gut.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Mein Vater ist 45 Jahre an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
45 Jahre?
Ja, er war zu jung.
Oder sehr jung, Entschuldigung.
Ja, es tut mir leid.
Sterben denn auch junge Leute daran?
Ja, natürlich.
Kann sein.
Ein Herzinfarkt hat viele Ursachen.
Aber die Medizin entwickelt sich immer.
Warum ist das denn?
Es ist sehr wichtig für alle, nicht nur junge Menschen.
Geburt, Erblich, Lebensstil, Rauchen, Alkohol trinken.
Es gibt viele Risikofaktoren für den Herzinfarkt.
Okay.
Ja, das kann sein.
Und meine Mutter ist mit 65 Jahren an Brustkrebs gestorben.
Brustkrebs.
Das tut mir leid auch.
Frau Stetner, sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich bin geschieden und lebe allein.
Was machen Sie als Berufslehrer?
Wie gesagt, arbeite ich als Taxifahrerin.
Das ist ziemlich stressig, Herr Doktor.
Und wohnen Sie alleine oder mit Ihrer Familie?
Ich habe keine ganze Familie. Ich bin geschieden.
Ich habe eine Tochter, die drogenabhängig ist.
Sie nimmt im Moment an einem Methadon-Programm teil.
Zurzeit lebe ich alleine.
Ach so, das tut mir leid.
Ist Methadon gefährlicher, Herr Doktor? Kann man darauf verzichten?
Methadon ist auch ein Drogen.
Aber das ist gut zu hören.
Ihre Tochter hat ein Methadon-Programm aufgenommen.
Methadon wird anstatt andere Drogen gegeben.
Und dann im Laufe der Zeit die Abhängigkeit reduziert.
Ich hoffe, Ihre Tochter nach dem Programm
sollte mit Methadon oder Drogen frei sein.
Hoffentlich.
Frau Stettner, ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ich bedanke mich. Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Herr Doktor, was machen Sie für mich?
Frau Stettner, ich habe den Verdacht auf Magen-Darmentzündung.
Deswegen würde ich gerne ein paar körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Blut für Laboa-Untersuchungen abnehmen.
Dann können wir wieder bespielen.
Sie sollen jetzt hier warten.
Ich komme Ihnen zurück und erzähle Ihnen Schritt für Schritt.
Sobald ich verstehe, soll ich im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Ja, natürlich. Sie sollen hier bleiben.
Vielleicht sollen wir Sie in Ihrem Krankenhaus isoliert behandeln.
Oder isoliert aufnehmen.
Danke, Herr Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie.
Alles Gute. Auf Wiedersehen.
Vielen Dank. Ihr habt sehr gut gemacht.
Herr Özüvalı, Sie brauchen zuerst einen Anruf aus Laboan.
Ja.
Dann?
Klink, klink.
Özüvalı hier. Hallo.
Guten Tag. Ich bin Frau Müller am Apparat.
Herr Lorenz mit der Kaliumwerte über 5 mmol pro Liter.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Werte Ihren Oberarztin weiterleiten?
Ja, natürlich. Vielen Dank.
Danke schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag, Herr Özüvalı.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Aber bevor ich mit Ihnen etwas Wichtiges mitteilen möchte,
habe ich einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Es geht um Herr Lorenz Kaliumwerte 5 mmol pro Liter.
Das entspricht normalen Werte für die Kalium.
Sind Sie sicher, ob das Wert 5 mmol pro Liter ist?
Ja, ich verstehe, dass es so 5 mmol pro Liter ist.
Ich habe gehört, die Frau hat gesagt, dass der Wert über 5 mmol pro Liter ist.
Ja, sie hat gesagt, dass der Wert über 5 mmol pro Liter ist.
Hyperkalium oder?
Sie haben gefragt.
5,1 mmol pro Liter ist normal.
Aber 5,9 mmol pro Liter ist Hyperkalium.
Ich habe das Recht.
Ja.
Okay.
Woher haben Sie die Hyperkalium?
Hast du meine Frage gehört?
Ja, ja, ja.
Welche Frage habe ich gestellt?
Welche Ursache?
Okay.
Hyperkalium, Kaliumreiche Ernährung und Dehydratation als Medikament.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass Sie über Hyperkalium gelesen haben.
Ja, ich bin überzeugt.
Aber bitte antworten Sie nur meine Frage.
Ja.
Können Sie mir bitte helfen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich kann gerne Ihnen helfen.
Als Ursache kann man bei Hyperkalämie, Neuropathie, Kaliumsparende Diuretik und
und demnach auch bei Chemo-Lies wegen Trauma oder Krebs nennen.
Okay.
Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei Hyperkalämie?
Bei der Hyperkalämie,
die Kaleme, Muskelschwerke, Reflexe, Kolik, Lähmungen,
Super.
Okay.
Am wichtigsten ist die Chemophilie.
Wie können Sie die Hyperkalämie behandeln?
Die erste Maßnahme ist Hydration, Kaliumarme Ernährung,
Kaliumgluttonat IV Infusion und Glukose-Insulin-Infusion.
Ja, bei leichten Fallen empfehlen wir Kalium.
Bei leichten Fallen, zum Beispiel zwischen 5,2 bis 5,9 Millimol pro Liter,
empfehlen wir Kaliumarme Ernährung.
Und wir überprüfen, dass die Medikamente des Patienten,
zum Beispiel Kaliumsparende Diuretika kann Hyperkalämie verursachen.
Und natürlich können wir Flüssigkeit geben.
Bei schweren Fallen verabreichen wir Glykonat IV,
zur Protektion des Herzens, und Insulin-Glukose IV auf Salbtammer inhalativ.
Ja, Salbtammer inhalativ.
Okay. Was haben Sie heute für uns noch?
Herr Professor, ich habe hier noch etwas zu meinen Kollegen gesagt.
Ich habe gestern die Noten von diesen Themen ausgesucht,
aber ich habe keine Urzakalerien geschrieben.
Ich möchte nur an diese Begegnungen zu den Kollegen berichten.
Hyperkalämie, Hyperkalämie, Hyperkalämie.
Die Unterschiede sind, dass die Erwärmung von Hypoalkalose,
die Respiratorik von Hyperacidos, Respiratorik oder Metabolik,
die Erwärmungen sind komplett gleich.
In beiden Begegnungen sind die Erwärmungen,
die Erwärmungen, die Muskelflaschen, die Schwiegen,
die Reflexschwachen, die Obstipation, die Lehmung.
Nein, in Hypoakalämie ist die Erwärmung Obstipation, Paralytik,
aber in Hyperkalämie ist die Erwärmung Dysiore, Gastrokolik.
Obstipation, Hypoakalämie, Obstpation, Gagantype.
Ja, die Begegnungen sind Gagantype.
Aber in beiden Begegnungen sind die Lehmungen,
die Neurologischen Ausfälle, ein Festgleich.
Muskelschwachen, Lehmungen, Parasite, Reflexveränderungen,
aber gastrointestinale Befunde sind anders.
Ja, Hypoakalämie, Obstpation, Hyperkalämie, Dysiore
und Herzrhythmusstörungen erwarten wir beide und Kamaphilieman erwarten wir beide.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Es geht um Maria Stetner, 62 Jahre alt, 1,67 Meter groß und 69,5 Kilo.
Was ist das Geburtsdatum des Patienten?
Das habe ich nicht gefragt.
Aber das ist sehr, sehr wichtig.
Wir müssen es nicht vergessen.
Ja, ein Großfehler.
Ja, leider. In Düsseldorf ist das ein Großfehler.
Normalerweise im Notaufnahme fragt man diese Frage nicht.
Aber, ja.
Die stellen sich heute bei uns wegen seit gestern Abend bestehender kolikartiger,
welchformiger Oberbauchschmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen sind seit gestern langsam aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzen zahlen nicht aus.
Sie hatte gestern ein Mettbrotchen gegessen.
Nur Mettbrotchen?
Nur Mettbrotchen, ein Tremisot.
Mettbrotchen, ein Tremisot gegessen.
Und Tremisot.
Nach dem Essen sind die Beschwerden langsam aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzen zahlen nicht aus.
Die Schmerzen versterben sich bei Bewegung.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 oder 7 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Haben Sie den Patienten ein Schmerzmittel angeboten?
Nein, habe nicht.
Habe nicht gemacht.
Wollte Sie Schmerzmittel von Ihnen?
Nein, der Patient hat keine Schmerzmittel.
Aber während der Gespräch hat Sie mehrmals erwähnt,
dass Sie nur Hilfe für die Schmerzen brauchen.
Ja, sie hat schon gesagt, ja.
Dann bieten Sie einfach ein Schmerzmittel.
7 und 6 und 7 sind hoch.
Nicht so hoch, aber Sie können anbieten.
Brauchen Sie ein Schmerzmittel?
Ich kann Ihnen sofort ein Schmerzmittel geben.
Das ist eine Reaktion.
Dann kann der Patient sagen, nein, ich brauche momentan kein Schmerzmittel.
Ich kann meine Schmerzen aushalten.
Dann kann er sagen, ich versuche, so schnell wie möglich das Geschlecht zu beenden.
Das ist eine Reaktion.
Das ist eine Empathie, eine Empathie, eine Empathie, eine Empathie.
Wenn Sie 6 oder 7 hören, können Sie das öffnen.
Dann können Sie die Schmerzen beitragen.
Begleitend klagt sie über die Übelkeit.
Gestern hatte sie dreimal Erbrüche.
Das war die gelbe Schleimung.
Sie hatte seit heute Morgen auch Durchfall.
Sie waren wässrig.
Am Anfang hellrot, aber jetzt dunkelrot.
Sie berichtet seit gestern Abend Herschläsen und Appetitlosigkeit.
Heute Morgen hatte sie das Fieber gemessen.
Das wurde gestern 39, heute Morgen 38,3 Grad Celsius gemessen.
Wegen der Erbeneinheit ergaben sie seit gestern Abend Müdigkeit, Hüsten.
Wegen Arbeitsstress, dauerhaftige Schlafstörungen.
Bei der Vorerkrankung erbran sie Kopfschmerzen.
Wegen Stress.
Seit 10 Jahren hatte sie einen Reismagen und chronische Hüsten.
Die Operation wurde verleint.
Medikamentös nimmt sie Badrian bei Bedarf und täglich A.S.S. 500 mg und Maloxon Tablet bei Bedarf.
Sie hat Amoxilin Allergie.
Sie reagiert auf anaphylaktische Reaktionen oder Schock.
Zu den Nöchtern raucht sie täglich Zigaretten seit 6 Lebensjahren.
Im Akkoholkonsum wurden 2 Gläser Wein pro Woche beacht.
Im Drogenkonsum habe ich die Fragen vergessen zu stellen.
Bei der Familienanamnese der Vater verstorben an einem Herzanfall mit 45 Lebensjahren.
Hat sie auf Brustschmerzen, Rufnot, Engelgefühl momentan?
Die Patientin hat Herzrasen, aber Brustschmerzen hat die Patientin nicht gesagt.
Bei Oberbauchschmerzen sollen wir diese Fragen stellen, weil der Myokardinfarkt unter Bauchschmerzen verstecken kann.
Der Vater hat einen Herzanfall.
Bei der Vegetative Anamnese haben wir eine Schema.
Fieber, Schützfrozen, Kaltschweiß, Apathie, Gewicht, Schlafstörungen, Brustschmerzen, Engelgefühl, Rufnot, Herzrasen, Gastrointestinalsysteme.
Wenn Sie so denken, dann vergessen Sie nicht.
Bei der Mutter haben Sie auf einem Brustkrebs mit 65 Lebensjahren verstorben.
Die Mutter ist auf einem Brustkrebs mit 65 Lebensjahren verstorben.
Sozialanamnistisch ist sie Taxifahrer von Beruf geschieden.
Sie wohnt allein.
Sie hat eine Tochter. Die Tochter ist ein Methadonprogramm.
Die Tochter befindet sich in einem Methadonprogramm.
Warum?
Die Tochter ist drogenabhängig.
Welche Drogen?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Die Tochter hat es nicht gesagt, aber das Methadonprogramm ist eine Ersatztherapie für opioideabhängige Menschen.
Sollen wir die Drogenabhängigkeit ausführen?
Nein, nein. Aber Sie sollten diese Information als Arzt wissen.
Der Methadon ist eine Ersatztherapie für Opioide.
Ersatzdrogen.
Ich denke aktuell nicht Ersatzdrogen.
Aktuell ist es eine grundsätzliche Drogen.
Der Methadon ist eine Drogenabhängigkeit. Aber unter ärztlichen Kontrollen ist das nicht gefährlich.
Denn der Arzt gibt den Patienten jeden Tag nur eine Drogenabhängigkeit.
Wenn der Patient nicht mehr eine Drogenabhängigkeit hat,
dann ist er nicht mehr ein Ersatzdrogen.
Er ist ein Drogen, aber er wird in der Ersatzdrogenabhängigkeit verwendet.
Er ist ein Drogen, der sehr stark auf den Ersatzdrogen abhängt.
Um das zu reduzieren,
wird er den Patienten systematisch mit dem Methadon verwendet und dann in der Kontrolle des Doktors,
mit dem zu Beginn, mit dem hohen Drogen, und dann wird er langsam verwendet.
Der erste Punkt ist, dass der Methadon ein Opioid ist.
Natürlich. Ich habe den Patienten gesagt, dass Methadon ein Opioid ist.
Seine Reaktionen sind sehr schön.
Das gefällt mir.
Das wird in diesem Fall zuviel sein.
Das wird zuviel sein für den Patienten. Ich habe es für die Teilhüter.
Auch der Anamnese hat den Verdacht auf akute Gastroenteritis.
Deswegen nach dem Versorgung des reinen Tieres,
durch Rheumflaschen, akute Begonung, Progredient Kolikartik, Bauchschmerzen,
das Erkriegen ist ein lindertes Faktor.
Sie hat auch einen politischen Durchfall für eine akute Gastroenteritis.
Welche Ursachen wissen Sie für Gastroenteritis?
Was ist die häufigste Ursache für Gastroenteritis?
Die erste Ursache ist viral, bakteriell, toxin.
Und die vierte Ursache, mir fällt nicht ein, viral, Parasiten.
Vira, Neurovirus, Adenovirus, Bakteriell,
meist Salmonella, Kampflopapter und Schiella.
Und E. coli, entorahemorrhagic, entorheproxin, Echeliaxen, Coli.
Müssen Sie die Erregung zum Gesundheitamts melden?
Ja natürlich. Die andere Ursache muss man isolieren.
Im Krankenhaus muss man die Anmeldung verpflichten.
Warum isolieren Sie die Patienten und warum melden Sie die Laborergebnisse?
Das ist eine sehr ansteckende Infektion für ältere Menschen.
Die immundefizitischen Menschen sind sehr gefährlich.
Deswegen sollen diese Gastroenterisien infektioniert werden.
Die Patienten sollen ins Krankenhaus oder in ein anderes Gebiet isoliert werden.
Okay, bitte schön. Welche Differenzialdiagnose kommen in Frage?
Differenzialdiagnose kommen in Frage.
Occipensipä und Akut-Burnell-Syndrom.
Okay, wir haben schon gesprochen.
Aber leider habe ich die Coronarzentrum-Fragen zu stellen.
Ich würde gerne als erstes körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Blutbild, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Entzündungwerte, Kulturprobe.
Und dann ein Elektrocardiogramm durchführen.
Bitte vergessen Sie das Wort nicht.
Zum Beispiel, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie die Unterhaltung durchführen.
Ich würde gerne Blutbild, Nierenwerte, Leberwerte, Herzensüme,
Kreatinkennas, MB und Genom-Parametern durchführen.
Dann ein EKG in Ruhe.
Am Anfang haben Sie durchführen gesagt.
Dann weiter andere Wörter. Zum Beispiel bestimmen lassen oder überpüren.
Bestimmen lassen. Oder kontrollieren lassen.
Jede Satze benutzen Sie andere Wörter.
Danach würde ich ein EKG verschreiben.
Danach würde ich gerne ein Sonoabdomen veranlassen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich einen CT angemeldet.
Und auch gegebenenfalls eine Phasodiodinoskopie und ein enthologisches Konzil.
Wo können Sie diese Patienten behandeln? Wie?
Auf jeden Fall möchte ich diese Patienten in Stationen insoliert aufnehmen.
Danach?
Als Initialtherapie würde ich gerne eine Sekunde zu großlose SZUGANG legen.
Und dann Füllungspflicht zu fahren. Je nach Ergebnissen.
Elektrolysis Substitution.
Dann Antibiotikum und Antibiotikum verschreiben.
Dann die Patienten nicht besuchten.
Ich hoffe.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen verletzt.
Aber natürlich habe ich ein paar Fälle.
Ekrem, die Geburtsdatum, Personaldatum sind sehr wichtig.
Das ist die Düsseldorfte, die Ölmüde.
Wie soll ich das sagen?
Er hat gefragt, ob das eine Operation ist.
Das ist keine Operation.
Das ist eine Geburtshilfe-Methode.
Ich habe das nicht gesagt.
Geburtshilfe-Methode, so viel.
Man kann das ausprobieren.
Ich möchte es wiederholen.
Ich gebe dir eine Anzahl.
Ich möchte nur die Anamnes-Karte des SZUGANGs und die Anamnes-Karte des SZUGANGs bezeichnen.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Ich habe es nicht bezeichnet.
Ich sage es jetzt, 20 Minuten lang.
Nur, wie viele Mal Aliskut sagt.
Es wird sehr schief.
Man beginnt zu verringern.
Nur 20 Minuten lang.
Wie viele Mal Aliskut sagt.
Ich habe keine Smok.
Ich bin nicht krank.
Du hast es so in deinem Gesicht.
Ich bin erst mal aufgewacht.
Vielleicht ist das deshalb.
Ich war ein bisschen schlafen.
Danke.
Ich möchte dich nicht beitragen.
Danke, Epeka.
Wie soll man eine Anzahl auf 5?
Man muss sich das dann anregen.
Wie viele Mal Aliskut sagt.
Ich möchte dich nicht beitragen.
Ich habe keine Anzahl auf 5.
Das ist das, was ich nicht verstanden habe.
Ich kann etwas zurückfragen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das so macht, wenn man es in der Labo macht.
Aber egal, was man nicht verstanden hat.
Man muss sich das immer wieder fragen.
Man hat eine normale Anzahl auf 5.
Man hat eine anormale Anzahl auf 5.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das 5.9. auf 5.5. sagt.
Aber wenn ich so etwas mache,
dann kann ich es nicht beantworten.
Deswegen würde ich mich fragen,
ob man eine Anzahl auf 5.5.
sagen kann.
Ich würde es nicht sagen.
Was meinen Sie, über fünf Jahre gibt es noch eine Bechte?
Genau so.
Bitte, Ibrahim.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ibrahim Akdunar.
Ich möchte Ihnen meine Patienten vorstellen.
Bevor wir anfangen, werde ich Ihnen einen Anruf vom Labor mitteilen.
Ok, bitte schön.
Nachdem mir vom Labor übermittelten Informationen der Patienten Herr Lorenz,
und er hat einen Kaliumwert von über 5 Millimol pro Liter,
dieser Wert entspricht einer Hyperkalämie.
Wenn Sie erlauben, kann ich mit der Vorstellung der nächsten Patienten fortfahren, Frau Oberarztin.
Natürlich, bitte schön.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin gesehen.
Es handelt sich um Frau Maria Stettner.
Sie ist 62 Jahre alt, 1,67 Meter groß und wiegt ungefähr 60,5 Kilo.
Die Patienten stellen sich seit gestern Abend langsam aufgetretenen Diffusenbauchschmerzen im Oberbauch vor.
Laut der Patienten strahlen die Schmerzen nicht aus.
Darüber hinaus traten sie nach dem Verzehr von Metzbrötchen und Tramousse langsam auf
und nahmen im Verlauf an Intensität zu.
Die Patienten beschreiben die Schmerzen als krampfartig und wellend für mich.
Die Schmerzintensität beträgt auf der NRS 6 bis 7 von 10.
Begleitend treten überall zweimalige Erbrechen Herzrasen sowie seit heute Morgen Durchfall auf.
Der Stuhl ist zunächst wässrig und hellrot, später dunkelrot.
Seit gestern Abend liegt die Körpertemperatur der Patienten bei bis zu 39 Grad Celsius, aber heute 38,3 Grad Celsius.
Zusätzlich bewichtet sie über Insomnias und Müdigkeit.
In der Vorgeschichte finden sich chronische Kopfschmerzen, Reismagensyndome und chronische Hüften.
Operativanämmlich gibt es keine Operation.
Die Patienten nehmen bei Bedarf Aspirin 500 mg und Maloxan für Reismagensyndrom und bei Bedarf Padrían für Schlafstörungen.
Sie hat Amoxicillin-Allergie mit Atemnot und früher Adrenalin bekommen.
Die Patienten rauchen seit 36 Jahren etwa 10 Zigaretten täglich, das entspricht 22 Packungsjahre.
Sie trinkt abends gelegentlich eine Flasche Bier. Drogenkonsum liegt nicht vor.
Sie arbeitet als Taxifahrerin, sie ist geschieden und hat eine Tochter.
Ihr Tochter ist unter Methadon-Therapie.
Ihr Tochter ist im Alter von 65 Jahren an einem Mammarkarsenom verstorben.
Ihr Vater ist mit 45 Jahren an einem Joghurtinfarkt verstorben.
Die anämmlichen Angaben liegen am wahrscheinlichsten vor.
Dafür sprechen die Postbrandial-Oberwachschnassen durch Fall, Ubelkeit und Erbrechen.
Differenziell der Nostrisch sehe ich eine akute Pankratitis sowie eine Koliosystitis in Betracht.
Als nächstes füre ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durch und veranlässe eine Blutentnahme zum Ausschluss einer Herzerkrankung.
Schreibe ich ein EKG.
Im Labor bestimme ich Blutbild, CRP, Elektrolüter, Lipase, Leberwerte, Geronungsparameter sowie Herzmuskelenzyme.
Zusätzlich veranlässe ich eine Stuhldiagnostik, eine Abdomentshornographie, eine gegebenenfalls Oesophagogastodiagnoskopie sowie gegebenenfalls Abdomenstädte.
Laut der Patienten sagt der Stuhl Blutbeimengung.
Daher nehme ich die Patienten stationär auf, um die weitere Abklärung durchzuführen.
Als Therapie blanze ich eine Flüssigkeit zuvor mit Elektrolyten, Anergetikum, Antiemetikum, gegebenenfalls Antibiotikum nur bei schweren Verlauf.
Das war's. Danke schön Frau Ubel-Astin.
Okay. Ibrahim Hüdem, du hast es sehr gut gemacht. Bist du das mit Unterstützung gemacht oder hast du es spontan gemacht?
Ich habe es seit dem Tag gemacht.
Ich habe ein Schablon ausprobiert, um die Worte mit den Wörtern zu nehmen.
Ich hoffe, dass ich es gut machen kann.
Das ist sehr schön. Du kannst es für jeden Fall machen.
Du kannst es vor einem Tag vorbereiten.
Aber wenn du es hier ausprobieren willst, dann nicht.
Nur die Anamneskennung, die der Patient mit sich selbst gibt.
Aber die Worte selbst zu machen.
Ich habe keine Schablon in der Hand, aber ich habe nur ein paar Schablon, die ich mir an die Hände schenke.
Ich habe sie alle in den Chat-GPT gelegt.
Denn die meisten Schablonen sind die gleiche.
Ich habe einige Schablonen gefunden.
Ich habe sie in die Indikative gelegt.
Ich habe die schönsten Worte ausprobiert.
Ich habe die vorher nicht genannten Worte ausprobiert.
Du kannst es so machen.
Nehmt nicht ein Schablon für jeden Fall.
Nehmt ein Schablon und schreibt die Symptome für jeden Fall in das Schablon.
Sonst könnt ihr es nicht ausprobieren.
Ich habe gestern das Schablon in der Hand festgestellt.
Jetzt werde ich es in die Hand schicken.
Ich hoffe es.
Du hast es hier ausprobiert.
Ja, ich habe es hier ausprobiert, aber ich werde es in die nächste Zeit vorbereiten.
Ich habe einen Fehler gemacht.
Es ist nichts wichtig.
Wir machen es hier um zu lernen.
Keine Sorge.
Ist es eine Struktur, die du bezeichnen oder bezeichnen kannst?
Nein, diese Struktur ist sehr gut.
Ich habe es in der Hand festgestellt.
Okay, ich habe es in der Hand festgestellt.
Ja, das war eine wirklich schöne Ausbildung.
Es war toll.
Ich kann dir sagen, dass du dich nicht zu sehr zerstören musst.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass du nicht zu sehr sprichst.
Das ist nicht zu schwer.
Aber ich habe es in der Hand festgestellt, weil ich es nicht in der Hand habe.
Du kannst es nicht so einfach machen.
Ich habe immer einen Fehler gemacht.
Das hat mich geholfen.
Jetzt habe ich eine andere Struktur für mich.
Aber du kannst es dir anstehen.
Ja, ich kann es dir anstehen.
Danke für deine Behandlung.
Ich habe kurz gesagt, dass es in der ersten Zeit 6 Fakate gibt, die mit dem Gastrointestinal System ausgehen.
Alle sind sehr ähnlich.
Die Anamnes-Aufnahme-Fakate sind sehr ähnlich.
Ich habe mich nicht von den Fakaten mit dem Gastrointestinal System ausgehen.
Wie oft müssen Sie zum Stuhlgang auf die Toilette gehen?
Wie ist es mit dem Vasalasen?
Ist es in Ordnung?
Ich habe hier die Fragen von Elbrechen, Vasalasen und Stuhlgang.
Ich kann auch Fiba hier aufstehen.
Fiba, weil es in der Gastrointestinal System Fiba gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es andere Fiba gibt.
Es gibt viele Fakate, die ausgehen.
Vertikulitis gibt es.
Es gibt keine Koolidol-Nutriensis.
Aber wenn du Kolanjitis in den Vakuum-Vakuum aufstehen willst, ist es Fiba.
Fiba ist hier.
Das war's.
Dann kommt die Anamnes-Aufnahme-Fakate.
Alle sind sehr ähnlich.
In den Schreien der Patienten gibt es Folgefülle, Blackung,
Gastro-Ösefagel-Refli, Zollbrand.
Es ist nicht so wichtig, wenn Sie das nicht wissen.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, können Sie das fragen.
In der Gastrointestinal Systeme ist es schon schwierig.
Dann fragen wir Apathit, Gevecht und Schlaf.
Dann ist es fertig.
Dann kommt die Anamnes-Aufnahme-Fakate.
Das ist so in allen Fakaten.
Wenn ein Patient eine Anmerkung hat,
dann wird er in die Anamnes-Aufnahme-Fakate.
Wenn er keine Anmerkungen hat,
dann ist das das Format.
In den Reaktionen gibt es eine Reaktion von Hausarzt.
Wenn ein Patient nicht lange im Haus ist,
dann ist der Patient nicht sehr gut.
Wenn der Patient nicht lange im Haus ist,
dann ist er nicht sehr gut.
Wenn er nicht lange im Haus ist,
dann sind seine Äindr unsere Wünsche und Gelben fleshen.
Richtig vieles,
was ich vorhin gesagt habe,
dass es etwas um injectionsale Ped faux war.
Ich kann nur darauf denken,
dass wenn das ein Virus ist,
Das ist genug für seine Frau.
Welche anderen Reaktionen hatten Sie?
Ich habe etwas gesagt.
Sie haben etwas gefragt.
Sie haben etwas gesagt.
Woher war das, woher war das?
Die Frage, woher das herrschen war, war sehr schön.
Ekrem hat es auch sehr schön erklärt.
Sie haben dreimal gebrochen.
Seit gestern Abend durften sie.
Sie hatten schon viel.
oder nach dem Essen.
Dann kann man ein paar Fragen über den Essen stellen.
Ein paar Fragen.
Wie heißt das, wenn man etwas komisches macht?
Oder war das Essen frisch?
Oder ist das Fertig?
So ein paar Fragen.
Das ist auch eine Reaktion.
Der Patient kann sich fragen,
kann er ein etwas komisches Essen füllen?
Man hat eine Reaktion gemacht und gesagt,
dass man die Frage gefragt hat.
Das ist eine Reaktion.
Und in diesem Moment oder jetzt...
Wenn die Jüngere über Hirsinfarkti sterben...
Es kann sein, dass die jungen Menschen wegen Herzrasen oder einem Herzinfarkt sterben können.
Aber natürlich hat die Medizin viele Fortschritte.
Ja, heute können auch Menschen sterben, aber die Medizin hat auch die Erleichterungen.
Ekrem abe hat hier auch eine gute Antwort.
Er sagte, dass könnte sein, aber dann hat er gesagt, dass die Medizin viele Erleichterungen hat.
Dann hat er gesagt, dass die Medizin vieler Fortschritte gibt.
Alta, Labelsstil, genetische Belastungen.
Es gibt viele Fortschritte, die natürlich möglich sind.
Ich habe normalerweise gesagt, dass die jungen Menschen wegen Herzinfarkt sterben.
Ich habe das so gemacht.
Ich glaube, es gab nichts anderes.
Ich habe die Frage, ob die Medizin drogen ist, bei der ich die Methadon-Programme, die Methadon-Teilung beantworten kann.
Ekrem abe hat eine sehr gute Antwort.
Ja, Methadon ist eine Ersatzsubstanz für Opioid, aber unter Arztlichen aussieht es nicht gefährlich.
Ich hoffe, dass Ihre Tochter nach dem Methadon-Programm sowohl methadonfrei als auch opioidfrei sein soll.
Ich bin ein Zeysor.
Das kann man so nennen.
Ich habe das so gesagt.
Haben Sie etwas zu fragen?
Vielleicht etwas zu den Reaktionen, zu den Fragen.
Vielleicht etwas, das Sie mir vergessen haben.
Herr Professor, das ist sehr gut.
Ich habe noch immer Probleme mit der Schale der Anamnes.
Ich habe schon immer ein Problem mit der Schale der Anamnes, die ich nicht in der Medizin benutzen darf.
In der Medizin, für example, habe ich es nicht benutzt.
Da habe ich eine Frau gesagt, die ich nicht in der Medizin benutzen kann.
Ich hatte vor ein paar Tagen, in der Medizin, eininisierte Schale der Anamnes.
Ich habe das auf der 5. Verteilung gesagt.
Dann...
...laute A, B, C, D, Depatiente, C, D, C, M, D, C, D, Plötzli, Nachtem, S, Aufgetretten.
Ich habe die Aufgetretten auf der 2. Verteilung gesagt.
Wenn es auch ein Tetikleid ist, dann habe ich das auf der 5. Verteilung gesagt.
Also erst auf der 5. Verteilung, dann...
...wie es sich erlaubt hat, wenn es ein Auslöse ist...
...d.h. am Anfang, als ich die Anamnesik nutze, nutze ich die gleiche Art hier.
Das ist es.
Dann...
...die Spezies.
...die Stätten.
Und dann...
...der Faktor, den ich vorhin gesagt habe, wenn es einen Fertigsten gibt.
...und dann...
...das ist es nicht.
In diesem Fall ist es nicht so.
Im 5. Verteilung hatte ich die letzte Art.
Das ist die Art, die die Anamnesik nutzt.
Also da entsteht eine Verrückung.
Wenn es ein Aufgetreten ist, dann ist es vorbei.
Das ist ein 5. Verteilung, ein Versand.
Deswegen ist es wirklich komisch, sie an die anderen Seiten zu benutzen.
Am Anfang, in dem Moment, wurde es ein 5. Verteilung, aber es geht weiter.
Für die, die es weiter machen, muss man schon den 5. Verteilung benutzen.
Das ist die 2. Verteilung, die weiter geht.
Im 5. Verteilung, das ist das Fua von Baba Afşim Ersin.
Aber wie ist es erlaubt? Ich sage es dir.
Der Herr hat gesagt, dass er gestern plötzlich angefangen hat.
Das ist die Angelegenheit.
Gestern hat Baba Afşim Ersin gestern angefangen.
Er hat angefangen.
Wenn er so sagt, dann...
Aber du musst dich hier immer wieder fragen.
Du hast nur den einen vorgegeben,
dass du momentan auf der Bühne bist.
Du musst das fragen.
Du sagst, dass du in Tishmars bist.
Du hast die Gehenze wieder weg.
Was hast du hier gesagt?
Habe ich es immer noch?
Oder war es immer noch?
Wenn du dich hier immer wieder fragen,
dann ist es schon alles entstanden.
Ist es noch etwas anderes?
Nein.
Dann, bis morgen.
Ich sage es allen.
Ich sage es auf jeden Fall.